I'm I'm a little upset with our next
presenter samuel l.jackson who beat me
out for the role of shaft
he had whole black take on the role that
evidently I didn't have ladies and
gentlemen samuel l.jackson
most films work from a script where the
action is meticulously plotted and
everyone on set knows exactly what is
supposed to happen
but there is another kind of filmmaking
that finds its story as it goes along
counting heavily on intuition and the
real emotions of very real people to
tell their story it is called
the documentary and for our purposes
they come in two sizes short and
feature-length first the documentary
Short subject category where the subject
matter is as varied as life itself
here are the nominations Big Mama Tracy
sera team curtain call Chuck Braverman
and Steve kalapa dolphins Greg
MacGillivray and Alec Laura Moore the
man on Lincoln's nose
Daniel rain on tiptoe gentle steps to
freedom Eric Simonson and me live demos
and the Oscar goes to Big Mama Casey
Sarah tree
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Tracy Sarah team
wow talk about beginner's luck
thank you very much members of the
Academy this is my first film but I
certainly didn't work with beginners I
thank the entire team of documentary
people at HBO
Jeff bukas Chris Albrecht and most
especially Thank You Sheila Nevins also
Jeff Bart's
Julie Anderson there are a few people
who were with me from the very beginning
three years ago
Mitchell block Lisa Lehman and my
cinematographer Tamara Goldsworthy I'm
here because of my family and friends
thank you I wish I could name you all
lastly I want to dedicate this award to
my film subjects Walter DS and his
grandmother viola who died unfortunately
in December at 91 I'm sure she would
want though to share this award with the
grandmothers like her who are struggling
to raise a generation of children whose
own parents abandoned them thanks very
much and thank you to all those
grandparents out there thank you
the second part of the documented
documentary category is films of
feature-length and they are into the
arms of strangers stories of the
Kindertransport mark Jonathan Harris and
Deborah Oppenheimer legacy Todd blending
long nights journey in today Frances
Reed and Deborah Hoffman Scottsboro and
American tragedy
Barrett Goodman and Daniel anchor sound
and fury Josh Aronson and Roger Weisberg
and the Oscar goes to into the arms of
strangers stories of the Kindertransport
mark
Jonathan has and Deborah - hi
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Deborah Oppenheimer this
is the second Academy Award for mark
Jonathan Harris he won an Oscar for Best
Documentary Short subjects in 1967 for
the redwoods
this is an this is an honor of the
Kindertransport survivors who have
inspired us with their honesty and their
eloquence and their humanity and for
their parents who love them so much they
had the courage to send them away the
film is in memory of my mother who was
one of the 10,000 children and my
grandparents whom she never saw again
we'd like to thank everybody orna
brothers for their extraordinary leap of
faith particularly Barry Meyer Jerry
Levin and Bruce hos and bloom as well as
Dan Feldman and I'd like to thank my
family my friends my colleagues and my
partner Bruce Helford and I'd like to
thank our wonderful team particularly
Kaye Damon Don Lenser Lee Holdridge Gary
Rydstrom Dame Judi Dench and my lovely
wife it's been a great privilege as a
documentarian to share the pain and
triumph of the people in our film
they've enriched all our lives thank you